seeing that it is
1003 i'd like to call to order
[Music]
the
subcommittee work session for february 8
2022 for house bill 1454 fn relative to
permits for the sighting of new
landfills
with that
based on our rich discussion that we had
when representative tucker was here and
presented the bill before the committee
we have decided that we would like to
take
an additional look and work further with
the bill based on some of the concepts
that we had heard in committee
around various areas of the concept of
time to travel so with that
i'll call representative tucker
forward and i'll allow her a couple of
moments to talk with us and talk about
how
the changes have come about
and
thank you uh
very much representative murray
is this being filmed
i believe it's being live streamed yes
yes i just wanted to make sure that we
all
knew what was happening
i always like to know yes thank you
so what i've done today is i've copied
made copies of
the bill
that
we have
and then sent to ols
for review
and they made some recommendations
which we accepted
and then
in response to the discussion that came
up the other day when we made the
presentation
when director wimsat was here
we went through and made further changes
which we feel are discussable
and i have given copies to everyone in
the audience
as well as members of the committee
um
maybe not to
is that mr representative bixby do you
have one that this has the
annotated
and
so i hope that the
and i did not send this version
to office of legislative services
because i was afraid they would get
bogged down if we kept
making too many changes so my intention
was
to listen to the feedback from committee
members today
and see whether you like these words
or don't
or other changes
and i gather there may be other people
talking to today we can hear what they
have to say
and
at that point
possibly come up with
further
changes
which then would go to a well asked for
their
assistance
i'd let
our drafting attorney
know that
and she wished me well
so that's where i am uh
i think we have slimmed and trimmed
the build
a lot
and that it's a better bill
uh representative bixby made some
changes not only
that
read more easily but
seems to me it's important on this bill
more so than other kinds of bills
to have it so that
residents of the state
can tell what it means
and so the fact that it reads more
easily and is understandable
is a really important contribution
so
[Music]
thank you for
having this work session
great thank you for coming up here i
will um first open it up to the
committee members here just so that we
all are aware
um
the the folks here have the ability to
participate as well as but these are the
only members up here who have a voting
capability representative bixby is here
as well but
no he has no voting capabilities so
so with that i'll open it to the
committee members if you have questions
i'll recognize myself for a moment if i
may
um
so
i did have a couple of questions with
regard to
um
the original testimony that you had made
i had a chance to review
the link that you had provided with the
epa's source water protection area
document
here
and so i did have a question on
the
s the setback time frame i've noticed in
some places and states they have a six
year setback
some have a five year setback and and so
for the five years how did you determine
that five years was
what what you would prefer and i know
you had made mention to neighboring
states that some sometimes have more
um
stringent i i think that uh
we were trying to strike a compromise
years around a well head
there were as i recall
two five and ten years
and so that the five represented
a medium
and
we've not seen anything or dr finkel has
not in his research which has been quite
extensive
found anything that leads us to believe
that there's a perfect
answer but that is why we did that it
seemed like a
very
reasonable amount
do i see dr finkel
today no alas no okay thank you he is
however listening to the streaming
and is on the other end of a telephone
and cell phone and is texting if he
and i can read his
text in return if
if i misstate something
representative homula
thank you
i had a question about the the boxed
adequate and representative
on-site field testing is that does that
need to be i understand it was used to
to clarify in section b
um
does that need to be explained more
usually when there's
descriptive words you know adequate and
representative is that an understood
like a scientifically understood
uh two two words
i think it is uh representative means of
course it has to be more than one
um
and
a
view of
our department of environmental services
that this is this will lead to
reasonable discussion
between the agency
and uh an applicant
and that this is a reasonable
this is what that agency is to be doing
given the
overall guidelines of the law itself if
it passes
[Music]
the distinction of before we had some
things that
caused difficulty and concern on des as
part of
that required going on to private
property so we've eliminated entirely
the need to go on to
private property that's why the on-site
but
when i boxed it or
adam boxer who whoever one of us boxed
it
um
we felt that was a discussable
uh
and i have not
heard back i have high hopes that
director wimsat can be here today
i sent him of course a copy
and have not
heard back as to any opinions on
these boxed areas
and
obviously this is someone who will want
to pay attention to okay
and again the only reason i'm asking is
i just wonder who gets to decide
adequate you know i like to when we're
looking at things i like to make sure
that
there's no question when people read
um
what that that might entail and i'm
i'm wondering who gets to decide what's
adequate
i i think it's really des and they get
but based off of this
i mean they will they will make up what
is on a case-by-case basis is what i
understand okay
all right so there's apparently as you
deal with these various topics
uh the des deals with there is uh back
and forth with
applicants okay
all right thank you i'm just again the
reason i'm kind of getting to that is i
i wonder if you have somebody who's
trying to do a project and they have a
different idea of what adequate means is
there are we opening any door for
quibbling
you see i think i have this um
on the second page
yep i see it there thank you in lines 12
to 13 i'll read it just because it is
we added three words adequate and
representative
so the des would be able to advise
applicants to conduct the minimal amount
of testing
needed to roughly estimate
whether the soils and bedrock at the
site are very porous
or very impermeable
des has indicated that it would not need
to do rule making to further define
these three words but could work with
thank you sorry i should have went
straight to there first
well the whole point of boxing it was so
we would end up discussing it so you're
just right on target
all right so my comment is actually not
limited to just the specific piece of
legislation but in general when a
statute is
set forth for a department to
uh
to be the you know
to act on
it is the department is
empowered to
make the decisions relative to that
statute so in this case
the department would be the uh arbiter
of what is adequate and
representative
and but that but putting those words in
gives it a little bit more clear
guidance in terms of
uh
they're
saying
well if it's going to be representative
and representative is
you're probably aware that this is is in
fact a
technical term
that involves um
having enough samples to
uh cover the the
um
the the options and the data that's
needed so um
on a you know on a half acre site which
you wouldn't probably have but on a half
acre site one test well may be
representative but
on a
on a 200 acre site then clearly you're
going to need to have more test wells
than that in order to
uh get a representative sample of the
uh of what the soil the hydro
hydrological conditions are
around the entire area so uh so by
putting that in it just really clarifies
that yes this is in the purview of the
follow up if i may thank you
representative bixby
um
representative tucker did you have any
discussion too
regarding sort of the one mile so if
we're thinking of things in a circle
um and one mile out and then five miles
out when we're talking again about
representative testing
is there a requirement further to be
done
at a cadence of one mile three miles and
then five miles or anything like that or
is it just
again to representative bixby's point at
the discretion of the department i think
it's at the discretion of the department
and
and what is considered uh
which obviously over time changes
representative bixby i'd just like to
point out that in the
uh in the draft that uh with the boxes
on it that we're discussing
uh it does not indicate at any point
that
the
department would have the option of
requiring test wells that were not on
property owned by the
uh by the applicant
so um so the
essentially uh there are
there's a distinction made in it between
the actual land
solid waste disposal area which is uh
going to be probably less than the area
that is owned by the applicant
and
uh i would assume that uh normal
hydrological testing would involve
doing uh testing around the
circumference of the uh of the test area
of the disposal area
probably in that area that's not
disposable area but
is sort of around the perimeter
um but that's
that's
a little bit of an assumption on my part
but i i think that uh yeah and i'm not
sure they could probably clarify that
i'm not sure that ownership is
necessarily the
the
best word to use it may be that someone
has permission
from someone or is paid for permission
to go on land
that someone else owns
that they would intend to buy if it
meets the qualifications
and so it's
it's the
that's
that's really
depends on the
what the applicant has to prove to an
agency that they have the right
to seek a permit
and that may or may not include actual
okay
i just think since this is recorded that
it's important to make those
thank you
senator bixby so so in this so um i
guess
the because the applicant may be
not purchasing the land until they have
the
uh until it's established that it be
actually makes sense then it would be a
matter of
having the right to access yes i i as a
reporter i cover planning board meetings
in other towns
uh from where i live and represent and
this is a very typical thing of someone
seeking a subdivision
to build houses
that they
very often
go through
the process before they actually the
developer makes the purchase
uh to make sure that all will work out
and there there's legal ways to say that
you have the right to go on property and
to dig and test and
so forth and that it's all with the
owner's permission that this is being
done with the understanding
that uh
um
i'll recommend myself for another
question again too on line 14 excuse me
on line five
um when we're talking about um any leak
or spill or other failure
i just was curious to know
um
what what types of failures that would
to talk about that further
this is on line five correct of the
of the that that was the word that those
were the words that omlas suggested
and i think that
other failure
is sort of an omnibus
term that
it would be something that des considers
a failure
but it was
in case it wasn't a leak or a spill
if it was a rip or i don't know what
else but it's to make it so it covers
what people
would generally agree is a failure
is there anybody from the department
representative contra
thank you madam chair
and thank you representative for taking
my question um a couple things that i
was just looking at it says that the
five-year clock starts
when the groundwater
so i guess my question is is
that the setback distance would be in
effect for five years
um
not that at any time should any
groundwater or any lake or anything be
uh contaminated
um
but i'm wondering why that's very
the five-year clock would start when
groundwater at the landfill site first
became contaminated
i can um representative bixby yeah i can
uh address that to some extent so um
the
uh in in the bill itself it doesn't
but
the the question was um
uh uh
having some way of including
in the
uh
in the legislation a way of indicating
what the point of the legislation was
why would one bother to track the
transfer the
the ground the movement of groundwater
in the first place
and another way of dealing this
with this might be
to um
take it out of
remove it from that location
and then have a
uh
an introductory sentence or two
saying the intent of this legislation is
to
make sure that if any landfill is you
know for any landfill that is put in
place
that uh if there were uh that there
would be a
buffer time of at least five years
if any leak or spill were detected
uh so the the location of that in that
sentence is not
critical but the the idea is that
uh there
the um
the way the the the
the point of having a setback is
to make sure that if something goes
wrong
then valuable resources won't get messed
uh and i based on uh previous testimony
from representative tucker it seems to
make sense that five years would be a
reasonable amount of time
to say okay if there is a spill then in
that amount of time
technical methods could be come out
could be established to
deal with the problem
if the
uh if if that if the spill moved
in like 60 days then there's no way that
would be able to be caught and given the
complications sometimes of dealing with
technical stuff even you know a year or
two years might not be sufficient to
deal with it but five years would be
so the idea is that
when we
when we figure out what the setback is
for
uh a
landfill from a resource we want to make
sure we have time to deal with
problems that might occur
and
uh and
so so that's why
uh that's why five years and
uh the
i'm i think it might actually make sense
to move that phrase of any leak or spill
or other failure to a different part
simply because the fact that you had a
question about it says that it didn't do
the job of explaining that's why we're
doing this legislation in the first
place so i think perhaps an in
sort of an initial
purpose
sentence for
for this um
this section might make more sense
thank you representative representative
kaplan
this might be a follow-up question for
representative bixby or for uh
representative tucker i'm not sure but
uh when you mention the five years
without the clock any mention of a clock
does that presume that it's the duty of
the owner to have some sort of
you know permanent
sites for testing
to be able to detect any leak or is that
or is that something that's in the rule
making or where does that work
what what
you know what would force the landfill
owner to
to maintain some sort of testing
capability to know when that clock it
i think that's all part of the
permitting process is that they agree to
conditions
and that's des's job to make sure that
they do
perhaps not as clear in new hampshire as
some places just how often that is
they again have the department has
discretion to set conditions
representative bixby yes i i i kind of
wish that uh there were some of here
from des to
clarify this but i believe that director
wimsat mentioned in
his testimony
something like you know they currently
have a four to six month yes
testing period so there are i think
there already is uh a requirement for an
established landfill to have
uh test wells
uh around the perimeter in order to um
to identify
any spill when it occurs that's right
clause so that everybody knows it's
every four months or every six months my
understanding is from his testimony is
thank you representative representative
contra
thank you madam chair
and thank you for taking my question
again um i'm just reviewing this and new
hampshire is is
has a lot of water
uh in the state i mean every city in
town except for one has
water a body of water in it
and i understand that it's the greater
of 200 feet or x times 5 feet based on
velocity
and i'm not a geologist and i don't
understand how
the velocity with water flows and
everything
but how will this affect
well
i think that
we can anticipate with the landfills
that we now have operating
and an extension to the permit at
carbury
most likely
we
really don't have a crisis of immediate
need for new landfills
but
obviously we will need some in the next
50 years
there it's a huge state and
there is no thought that there will not
be
thank you representative tucker i'd like
to
also further clarify it is my
recollection as well that your bill and
the subsequent amendment would not
affect any already existing inoperation
landfills who may seek her mature
for expansion that's right it's um
i think it's uh it's on line
[Music]
seven
nothing in this paragraph she'll be
construed to prohibit the expansion of
any landfills
that are in operation
at the time this act takes effect
thank you
is
representative kaplan
this is just a you know curiosity
question in the course of your research
i know this is not retroactive this bill
but
the existing landfills in new hampshire
how many of these how many of them would
meet this
requirement in your legislation do you
know
i don't
carbry is the very best example i i'm
really kind of i i live in
a town of randolph and represented it's
a member of the consortium that
the municipal consortium that runs
mount carberry and i've toured it a
couple of times and been you know very
impressed
but
the
tremendous amount of clay and the number
of years they have shows that they found
absolutely a
marvelous place
to put that
and
um there are undoubtedly other such
is
in excuse me i'll recognize myself for a
anything that's limiting
the ability for a landfill if if
if it were cited
and there were a failure of some sort
and the
time to travel
is is implemented
is there anything in your estimation
that
the landfill operator
already has currently in place that
would work in conjunction with this
for monitoring protection
yeah
they
the the state is monitoring
uh
my understanding is and it could be
faulty
um is that again
if there is something goes wrong
there's a
relationship between des and the
uh operator
where they have you know they have to
come up with the operator has to come up
with a plan and then it has to be
approved by ds
before it's implemented to make sure
that it is
state-of-the-art
remedy
and this again is a case by case this is
an agency operator
um
matter
i mean that's true of all remediation
projects
and it's i think we're going to see this
play out
with
all kinds of issues in the state with
other
with with chemical and other
pollutants in which
people are
trying to figure out just what is most
effective
and will remedy the problems that's been
identified
representative bixby yeah i'd just like
to comment on something that we haven't
touched on yet the
the um the original had the phrase uh
d shallow or deep groundwater and the uh
page with the
the recommend
the recommended revision with the boxes
has that changed to overburden slash
till and bedrock and i think that's a
significant improvement because it
really
clarifies
what the physical characteristics of the
of the different levels are
so i think i feel that that that
that revision makes it much clearer and
and should work so i brought a little
graphic
yes
is this the same one that you emailed to
the committee representative
great thank you very much i'll submit
this to the clerk for the record
you're welcome
um
yes i had to have a color printer
so i
i put where it should be blue
and
i am just locating mine here so yes i
see in your
um
in the schematic cross section that you
provided to us that it is talking about
the various types of rock till clay
um
and obviously even granite here in the
granite state and how that water can
change excuse me that soil can change
the groundwater flow based on the
density of the soils
um and i believe that that's what this
table is trying
to show correct
is that it's going you have shallow
wells being dug and then deeper ones to
address those cross sections for the
going down to the bedrock correct
fractured red rock or non-fractured
and there's no question that this is
the kind of wording which we'll
certainly want director wimsat and
others
uh expertise to make sure that we all
understand
what it means
and that really is this is the feedback
we need to know whether
it is clearer
representative kaplan
yeah i mean just along those lines uh
representative tucker is there i know
you probably don't have the answer to
this but it would be good to know is
there any intermediate layers where the
speed of groundwater flow could be
faster than the over
you know the overburden or the bedrock
is there an intermediate layer that they
need to be concerned about as well
that well i i i think this is where des
you know it is already part of the
applicant's process so they have a lot
of experience with
one thing that i had been looking at
sort of as a guiding document of sorts
is the
epa's
delineation of source water protection
areas and it seems like you had
referenced that a couple of times
and i did have some questions um about
whether or not
we are working with other local and sort
of regional
um
entities like
cooperative extensions or anything of
the like that would be used to help
monitor situations and areas
um
it was mentioned in the epa document
that that is one strategy so that might
be a question for director winsat
and i was just curious as far as
continual monitoring or anything like
that if that is something that is being
done
well all over the state we have closed
landfills and they have test wells i
know my little town
had had what was known as the dump
and that had to be
remediated
and test wells put in and part of our
yearly budget
i'm sure this is true all over the state
is to pay for the testing
and it's
not inexpensive
and it it's going to take place for
50 years
and so all over the state we have
people testing
closed landfills or what used to be
dumps things that never had the lining
and
because they don't have the lining
there's
more possibility
of
contamination and so they are being
tested all over the state
so somewhere we could dip into that
knowledge
i will find out where we're supposed to
do that
thank you representative homola
yes
tucker i just had a quick question do
you know if uh with the current
currently cited landfills that we have
here
are is there any um
is there any data out there that
actually discusses groundwater around
them as far as
looking at x feet per year now
is that that's a part of is there any
data out there that says
say this this landfill some of the
fastest moving water around that
landfill is this many feet per year does
anything like that any of that data
exist so we can compare that
well we have i think we've concluded
the mount carberry i'm sorry
i think mount carberry we have okay
and
i thought that was in my original
testimony but i could be wrong it might
be and i maybe perhaps i missed it i'm
just wondering if you have if you had
that that stat or anything like that
just so what i'm looking at is i was
looking at the obviously the 200 feet or
x times
uh
x times five feet
and i'm just wondering here we go thank
you on page three
of a four-page document
uh
of this one
it was my original testimony i have
copies of it if anyone would okay i have
it in my bag then okay so let me just
rather than merely talking about the
theoretical however i'm going to present
two actual examples of the years to
cause harm concept
as documented in coast county which of
course i represent
the application pending at des for an
expansion of the existing landfill at
mount carberry provides data showing
that contaminated groundwater from the
site would take quote
60 to 150 years
to reach a tributary of the androscoggin
river
the velocity was found to be about
50 feet per year there
it is located in appropriate soils and
bedrock
i have then
i did go on to compare it to the
site where the application has been made
in dalton
where the applicant
estimated the groundwater flows at that
site
at 9.5 feet per day or faster
if des code setback remains at 200 feet
from a water body
then the agency might only have as
little as 21 days to notice and respond
to a leak
at a site where groundwater flows this
quickly
follow up if i may i'll recognize myself
um so to that to that end i also am
curious to know
um there are many other
monitoring techniques in addition to
time to travel and i'm curious to know
would would would would there ever be a
time where more than one
monitoring technique would be necessary
depending on a circumstance are you
aware of
there being
multiple methods i think that the
the plus of using this
approach
is that
one of the concerns of des
is that they
end up as an agency spending a lot of
times on projects that don't go forward
and that's true whether it's northern
pass
large
residential developments there are all
kinds of things where des is tied up and
is spending expertise on projects that
don't go forward
so
finding a way to
sift
the wheat from the chaff
early was an enormous plus because
naturally there's a financial
consequence
and having an agency tied up with things
that don't go forward
you end up paying the salaries of people
who you know don't end up with a product
at the end so
very much i think
uh
dr finkel and others were looking for a
scientific way to
approach this problem
that would make it so that des would be
relieved
of having to spend a lot of time
on projects
that were located in places that
ultimately would be found to be
not suitable or sensible for a landfill
site so that's the big plus of this
approach is
it's used elsewhere issues in states
it's used by the federal government
and
it lends itself to an early appraisal
as to whether or not
it's a good place to do something
i'll ask another follow-up around that
area
um
and
there's the director thank you um so so
my other to that end i guess
is it your intent through this piece of
legislation then for time to travel to
be the initial testing mechanism
used and is that stated clearly in the
language that is the first
preferred method
with regard to your
yes it's a shift from
a one size fits all 200 feet that we now
have
and it's
it is it would be the
first step and if you didn't pass i
think in my testimony i called it the
exam if you couldn't pass this you
vernal pools wetlands all kinds of
things
some
more than others
and
this really is addressed to
the concept of worrying about the
groundwater that
is
where the greatest potential for harm
to
water resources
lies and that is why it is addressed
and that is why
a lot of time was spent by a collection
of people to find something
that answered all the
requirements that were given by
house members and senate members
in previous efforts
to find
ways to improve the state's
and when i heard it
i knew we
we really had something that was
doable
understandable
transparent
and scientific
and it's pretty hard to find something
that beats
those
so i'm i'm really here and i'm thrilled
to see director wim wimsat has arrived
i'm here to get feedback from you we
want to polish up this bill
i
spoke briefly with the chairman of your
committee before the meeting and he said
you know there's plenty of time we can
have work sessions
we want to get this right so i'm looking
for feedback
and uh
i'm happy to give way to
director said thank you thank you
representative for your generous time
before us and answering all of those
questions that we did have and for those
of us here who did have questions i
believe rep homeland maybe had one for
the director initially
i was just i was just curious how
in the statement adequate and
representative on-site field testing i
was just curious how adequate would be
defined
is that a
you know
maybe what's the thought process behind
that just so i'm just trying to find a
way i want to make sure that whatever
whatever gets considered it's not
setting up a point to quibble with
between say that the potential project
and des
and so that's what i'm just trying to
understand is
you know can you make the word adequate
oh
good morning director website good
morning and on my apologies i was uh
stuck in another hearing and could not
escape so i came here as soon as i was
available
um
gripson of hamlet for your question um
i think the language regarding uh
adequacy uh actually i just forgive me i
just want to take a look at it one more
but i don't see that language in there
that's because this is something that we
added oh this is a
point of discussion i thank you
sorry yeah so um
i i guess uh you know we we
many of the requirements that des
administers have to do with uh
relatively technical scientific
evaluations we rely on
applications and materials that are
often prepared by
professional engineers and professional
geologists and there's a certain amount
of
back and forth that occurs to evaluate
you know various requirements and
whether or not something has been
submitted
meets the standard if you will
adequate is is a tough word
representative is a word that we
commonly use the idea is that when you
do a sample or when you evaluate
something you're evaluating
a representative sample of it so
that's that's a term that we can we can
work with i guess if uh
in this particular example we're looking
at
um
in a hydrogeologist doing you know
probably a soil boring and then looking
at soil conditions
in the aquifer beneath the proposed
landfill site
and then trying to determine is that
representative um
of course the question is what scale is
it representative on right so certainly
um if uh if we know through the work
that's been done at a given site
the site is largely
sand and gravel
of a certain quality but there are a few
clay lenses then if a hydrogeologist
went in
and then got a sample from that clay
lens and tried to represent that it was
representative of the whole site we
would take exception to that and i think
this language would give us the basis to
do that
what i do think it is a little bit you
know
in the context of this bill we're
looking at what's the five-year travel
time of a particle of groundwater if you
will from the site to a given surface
water and as i testified before i just
don't want it to be lost in the
conversation
new hampshire's geology is very varied
it's with the our aquifers and the
materials in our aquifers are not
homogeneous they're very they could
their sand and gravel and silt and clay
and all those things
in certain cases they're very
homogeneous maybe you know everything
surface water may be a uniform sand and
gravel but in other cases it may not be
so
i i do just want to restate the concerns
i had before that um
if you're trying to evaluate that travel
distance
using only on-site sampling to do that
is going to have some limitations it's
going to basically it could bios you one
way or the other
based on whether the soils beneath the
landfill
that are representative of the site
are more or less permeable than the
soils that the groundwater would travel
to after it leaves the site but that's
you know
again that's that's the will of the
legislature how it wants to address this
bill but i i just what i don't want to
do is make it sound like the agency
believes that on-site sampling alone can
and precise
estimate of travel time because we're
not it's not clear that it can it may in
certain settings but in other settings
it may not so i just wanted to make sure
that folks are clear about that
representative kaplan
yeah i have a similar question about the
uh
the one of the other boxes in the
amendment which is having to do with uh
the different layers of
soil overburden slash till and in
bedrock
so the testing would have to take place
in both of those layers is there any
possibility of there being some kind of
intermediate layer which would be of
concern it's it's certain
again going to the sort of heterogeneity
and complexity of new hampshire's
geology there are sites where
there's a distinct
what we would all sort of think of as a
classic water table aquifer where it's
relatively permeable sand and gravel and
there's a certain water level in that
unit
and then you can describe it you know
pretty simply
then there could be what we call a
confining unit there could be a layer of
clay below that and some tighter you
know silty sandy materials beneath that
that are bounded by that clay layer and
the underlying bedrock in a way that
means that that kind of operates and
behaves as its own separate aquifer
groundwater flow velocities are
different
um you know maybe even flow directions
are different
um that that's and and potential in in
terms of uh
the
the uh the head value you know in a
confined aquifer like that you can have
vertical upward gradients you can have
on any number of things and then of
course you have the bedrock aquifer and
that can differ too there can be some
units of bedrock that are very tight
relatively unweathered and unfractured
that don't move much water
other you know surfacial bedrock may be
very weathered and move groundwater a
certain way but then as you get deeper
into the rock it moves
through a fracture system so
and again i'm not sure that helps answer
your question but the reality is geology
new hampshire is very complex
having said that i think that when we
look at a landfill and we look at how
it's cited and and
constructed
if you you it's reasonable to have if to
imagine a release from the liner system
and to make a reasonable
assumption about what unit that
contamination would migrate through and
where it might go after that so there
are thing there are
there is work that can be done
evaluating a specific site
that um can tell you a lot about um how
contaminants would move from the
landfill site
so i again i i don't want to by saying
that the
geology is complex i don't want to make
you think that we think that it's just
impossible that it's anybody's guess
that's that's not the case there there
are things that we assumptions we can
make
based on learning a lot about the
aquifer and the formation that it's
contained in
and knowing where the landfill how it
would be constructed and where it would
be in that formation we can make some
reasonable assumptions about
the most plausible
and and fastest groundwater migration
options
thank you
representative bixby yes so um i'm
wondering if the
the language of
adequate and especially representative
would allow you to require
uh in the case that there are
you have say the as you pointed out a
potential
within that overburden
a
gravelly layer and then a
silt layer or clay layer
by
with that term representative allow you
to require
that
the test uh
the test site
evaluate
both the gravity and the the
depth or layer i think so i mean i think
what our geologists would do is they'd
look at what we know about the formation
and they would make certain assumptions
about how groundwater would flow and how
contaminants might be transported and
they would look for the applicant to
provide
representative sampling and analysis of
those portions of the aquifer that where
they believe that that migration was
most likely to occur
thank you
representative kombra
thank you madam chair uh thank you
director for taking my question um just
listening to your testimony when we're
talking about citing a landfill just so
i understand this um and all the
complexities of our geography here in
new hampshire
if we're if they're looking at a
particular site
based on your testimony it sounds like
you have to do testing
also
offsite of where that
is that not true or are you
because you need to see how that
groundwater is going to flow if they
have a 200 acre site
you know and then
you know there's another parcel you know
some land next to that uh do you have to
look at how that groundwater interacts
with the groundwater of the site
under the current law and rules there
isn't necessarily a requirement to do
understanding that the the setbacks are
are numerical um there's not a there's
not a requirement to evaluate the
groundwater velocity to determine
whether
a particular um you know surface water
body is going to be impacted under
i am going to also ask a follow-up uh
around that
um
would there be any circumstance where
off-site testing would be voluntary you
would request that
folks were you would like to test an
area or the applicant is also sending
that when they're providing the
application to you folks
what
because you you do state that it's not
in statute to require the off-site
testing is there a mechanism that you
can seek that outside testing through
voluntary means
well if i guess if if we were evaluating
you know obviously when we evaluate a
landfill application we're evaluating
against the rules and the law that
governs our decision-making process
if they're a question were a question
that we could not answer
adequately
that we felt required some kind of
off-site data then we would ask for it
and i don't want to go too far down a
hypothetical but you know if we believe
that we needed that information to
answer
a particular question that we're
required under the law to answer in
order to make a permit decision then we
would do everything we could to make
sure we got that information
thank you
just so folks know we are running up
against a hard stop of 11 o'clock
um
i'd like to further discuss with our
subcommittee work group where we are
right now
if we feel we should proceed with
another work session if we've not fully
answered all of our questions
and i'd like to hear from you folks
rep stapleton welcome again
rep stapleton is also on the
subcommittee work session so i
turn to you first and then we'll kind of
um
i feel like the questions that that
that i had today were answered i think
that
i think the clarification of this for
the discussion was very helpful uh i
think that this
i think it clarified a lot in the
original bill
and i think that it also
uh put in some standardized language
that was
uh that eliminates any kind of
misunderstandings
and so
representative bixby did you have
thoughts as well yeah um i've just been
sort of uh making sort of scratched
notes here on a what we could have as a
preamble sentence to
clarify the purpose of the uh of the
section
so that we can move that of any leak
spill or other failure away from the the
middle there and make it clear that you
know this is the purpose of this section
is
to prevent to to
uh
make it possible for remedial action to
take place if there's a in the case of a
so at this time then would the motion
then be
to continue
i don't think we need emotion oh thank
you
to would you also like to continue
working on this through another work
session
uh i'm not sure that we need another
work session uh i if i
if i draft this and send it around to
the committee
uh
and then and
people are generally agreeable to it
then i think we might be able to just uh
draft an amendment and then go have a
brief work session before to pass it out
of subcommittee before
so representative pearl chairman
chairman
that's it that's all right
madam chair if i may
you may
i i think um probably the best
suggestion is you guys can
you know look at some language and we'll
schedule another work session for you to
sort of finalize
your and put your thoughts together and
it doesn't necessarily have to be next
week again we've got a bit of time on
this because we've got into the i think
it's march 10th is our our cut off date
of getting it out of the full committee
so you've got a little time if you want
to
sort of think about things and then we
can schedule another work session when
representative bixby so um i think we
may actually be able to pull this
together reasonably effectively but i
think in terms of using our term our our
time more efficiently i'm not as
sanguine about coming out of the next
session with a
uh an amendment that's ready to go
so uh i think and i think would make
sense for us when it gets around to to
doing the next uh
when it comes around to exacting i think
we should figure out doing the two that
we have not yet exact
uh at the same time
so uh
i think this this one probably won't be
sorry yes representative tucker before
we
somewhere along the line
if you all do your work if you could
then send it to me i will send it to ols
because
representative bixby i i think actually
what probably makes sense is for this
for the action for the amendment to come
out of our committee
uh and
uh so that is essentially signaling that
this is the committee amendment uh
absolutely but so so which means which
means we just need to make sure it goes
to all right so i'm new to this yes so
so uh so
we will so our committee will make sure
that it goes to ols
okay but you'll you'll send it back to
us somewhere along the way before we go
to oil so before we uh we will do the
sincere private sponsor we always pay
the courtesy of to the sponsors of the
bill of
uh circulating proposed amendments uh
including you on that circulation and
then but we will submit the
the
amendment to ols
representative bixby i think i am going
to create a second work session out of
this i would like to make sure that we
are answering the questions and if there
is anything that we still have for the
director
once we review everything here and if
representative tucker has any other
comments so i think that's what we will
do
thank you
um and so seeing that the time is
1105 sorry mr chair
sure
um
you
uh
all right good morning everyone it uh
we're a little bit late getting going
it's 11 10 but
we're going to convene the
subcommittee for
for uh animal protection subcommittee
and we are here to work on house bill
1186 relative to companion animals
so um
this bill has
we've had a slight work
a brief work session on it and this one
is so that we can be a little more
extensive in what we're looking at we
heard testimony from
many of the people that had concerns
with the bill about mandating
they
having the animals in the same facility
as the
you know the people that it could cause
issues with hotels or community centers
with the compatibility of animals so i
passed out two uh
two things rep gallagher had put
together an amendment through ols
032h which i handed out to the committee
and i put some on the back table there
for anyone who's interested
and the second one is some language that
i've been working with the akc
on a little bit of different language
that sort of
sort of
addresses the concerns and issues that
i think we all heard during the uh
during the testimony
about the trailers and the volunteers
and how they're not covered under health
so if it's okay with the committee i
think
i'd like to actually work off this
language that i gave you to start with
certainly we can i think it covers a lot
of what uh rep gallagher was trying to
do in his amendment as well
and but i i think this gives
to me it seemed to be a little more
clear as to what we were trying to
accomplish so if that's all right with
the committee we'll start there and
we'll certainly
kind of let it go to where uh to
so if you've had a chance to review the
language
here
that i that i passed out
again there's this is sort of two-fold
in what it's trying to accomplish
so during a declared state of emergency
containing an evacuation order any hotel
or community shelter which shelters
evacuated persons shall allow the
disaster animal response trailers on
site to accommodate any companion animal
belonging to such evacuated persons
the key point with that is
it's not
forcing the hotel to have them in the
hotel
and that was a major concern that we
were hearing it's just
would
they would have to provide room
somewhere in their parking lot so that
in essence the the animals and
their owners would be on the sort of
like the same campus they wouldn't be in
the same room necessarily but they would
all be on the same site you kind of look
i think what we'll do is just kind of
take this in pieces is there
any thoughts from the committee on
that part of the language
representative bixby um
i like this idea it claire i i think it
um deals with my major objection i'm
wondering
uh who is in charge of
making those
trailers available for the purpose
so it is my understanding that there are
four trailers already in new hampshire
and
the second part of this bill deals with
the sort of like the emergency response
team they would be the ones manning the
trailers
as far as who would be making them there
i would assume that would fall under
dhhs just as in to make sure that just
as they're housing the people they would
make sure that these trailers would be
available for
in in a state of emergency just like
they would the shelters for the people
so i assume it would fall under the same
purview right i i'd like to get some
clarification on that just just since we
one of the things that i think we saw in
some of the um
the
uh bill the laws from other states that
uh mr tory
uh pointed out to us
was that there's a certain degree of
variation in terms of how that
responsibility is meted out in different
states
and
i'd like to make sure that there is
there is
some way of assigning the responsibility
for doing that uh in new hampshire as
well as just hoping that there are some
trailers
so if i'm understanding correctly your
your question is who's responsible for
making sure the trailers are on site yes
who who's responsible for making them
making sure they're on site and that
they exist and that there's a sufficient
any further representative so on the
topic of sufficient numbers so there's
nothing in here that would say like so
there's four of them right now maybe
there's half dozen in the future
but we have a big evacuation and there's
there's just not enough of them
available like that's that's just a
resource issue there would be no mandate
on the the evacuation site
to take in animals if there was no
available trailer is that correct
correct okay and i i think that's
you know it just would make sure they
would have to make the accommodation to
have the trailers on site a place for
them if they're going to be an
evacuation site then they'd have to make
a spot somewhere on site for these
trailers there will be no negative
repercussions for them if no if no
trailer was available to be put on
correct
that's that's the way i read it yes okay
thank you
representative stapleton
this um
amount of animals
uh comply with local ordinances there on
line nine
are there a variability of numbers of
animals that can be contained by
residents throughout our state
or is that a uniform
number
because i i know that
there are some people who
are not licensed
for for dog
shelters
but they have more animals than they're
really allowed by ordinances they just
any
any research or background that we've
had in the committee and other
information other bills relative to how
we stand ordinance wise in the state on
that sort of a thing
i'm not aware of any research that's
been done at least not in my time here
i think we all know that certain
municipalities have
limiting restrictions on
well i do know what chickens
specifically that there are and
i don't know that i'm
aware of dogs and cats as far as the
municipality is concerned but they may
exist that's something we could
certainly look into but i think by
having that statement
in the bill that if there are if such
ordinances exist that we wouldn't be
causing a situation where they'd be in
violation of that
representative aaron question um
just as a different
something different um
i'm
wondering is there somewhere in statute
where we define
what constitutes an evacuation
i mean
you could be evacuated for a lot of
that's a great question i don't have the
answer for it
okay that might be one we need to look
into
well i think during a declared state of
emergency in the first place it would
have to be a declared state of emergency
containing an evacuation order so that
would have to be part of that state of
emergency
i'm not sure
what would you need for a definition on
that or what would you be looking for
well yeah i guess
i guess if it's in an evacuation order
do we have a statute that specifies what
how how an evacuation order
is defined or is it defined somewhere
i i'm certain that it is that
representative bixby yeah i i don't know
what the rsa is but i know that in order
for there to be a declared state of
emergency there really has to be some
rsa that allows the governor to declare
the emergency
and
i think that the
this is the way this is phrased here
during during a declared
state of emergency containing an
evacuation order so that is sort of
narrowing what sort of state of
emergency it is so we had a state of
emergency for covid but there was no
evacuation order associated with that
right so uh so i think what we need to
do is
uh find out uh what the
uh what the statute that is used to
declare a state of emergency is
and then cite that in in the in the
language and i i'm pretty sure that mr
tory might be able to help with it
okay
anything for uh representative von
polinski
so i i hate the nitpicking part of this
but i guess it's kind of our job here so
you mentioned chickens uh i think we all
know people who keep chickens in
enclosures on their property now they
don't tend to keep them in the house
um but is there some should we and i
have to assume there's some sort of
issue with
keeping chickens in close proximity with
snakes and dogs and everything else on a
trailer
is there is there a need to define this
a little closer as far as in a home so
you'll find that companion animals
does give definitions and chickens or
can be considered livestock in statute
so i only threw that out because i do
know that there are communities that
limit chickens i don't know if there are
communities that limit companion animals
they're very well maybe but i'm not
aware of them off the top of my head so
sorry i sort of confused it by
interjecting chickens no you're really
confused they really just kind of
brought up a sure question
they are livestock by statute okay thank
anything further on this part uh
representative bixby okay this is really
picky and it's sort of for final
drafting but uh
the any hotel or shelter uh which that
should be a vat
and
um
just just so we don't fail to catch that
later on sure
that's that's why it's always good to
have an english major on it i mean i
assume you don't want the gory details
on why what the difference is
we'll save that for the next work
session i have two other spots too that
need fixing that's fine
rsa 21-p colon 41
vi there should be also a c after that
in parenthesis because it's part c that
we're referencing there
i will take you at your word on that
since i haven't looked at it that's okay
i'm telling you and then i trust you and
that's your first mistake
um and then on the last line it says
other animal kept an enclosure that
might typically be found in a home yep
okay
all right so you've jumped ahead into
the other parts representative stapleton
i was just thinking
on that line 10
other animal kept in an enclosure that
might typically
be found in a home
um would it be helpful to have add the
word typically and lawfully found in a
home i mean you know people buying
pythons and alligators and who knows
what else
and
sometimes you only come across these
things in states of emergency when
public services are
at that point
and that's a rarity but
put the message out there that lawful
ownership is
affirmed
i understand your point because somebody
could have a bengal tiger there but i
mean i guess those wouldn't typically be
okay
okay so we all set on that first part do
we want to move on to the
come on up to the mic if you'd like that
way the folks who are listening online
can hear you
we don't want anybody to miss anything
so no that i'm not entitled to speak so
i appreciate the opportunity
i would just say that um
hey kurt just for the record why don't
you say who you are oh i'm kurt aronberg
i'm the state director of the humane
society of the united states thank you
we support the intent of this bill um
the changes made in your changes mr
chairman
i i would say
vastly make the make these two bills
very very different the language
um there are no there are not sufficient
depending on the size of the evacuation
we don't know what that would be
obviously
depending on
emergency
i guess it's dart shelters that you're
depending on
i would not necessarily say that in a
large scale emergency would be in any
way sufficient and i would recommend
that
there be some accommodation for
to say must allow trailers or another
reasonable accommodation
something some language like that
you'd be able to do it in one town maybe
in the gym there but
next door would not if they could make
some reasonable accommodation in another
room or another building
i think that would be improve this build
your language immensely
so you're suggesting uh
after she'll allow disaster
excuse me disaster animal response
trailers
you would like to add or other
reasonable accommodations on-site that
would be my okay
i'm not married to that language in any
way because i just came up with it and
i'm not a lawyer mr chair i think
that kind of makes sense because maybe
people would want to put up a tent
to keep an animal in sure that needs to
have maybe
not be in a contained building but
maybe needs to have more fresh air or
it's just something that would even be
able to be erected more temporarily
okay
certainly a good point thank you thank
you for watching appreciate it
anybody else certainly anybody in the
audience that's here if you want to
chime in just get my attention we're
anything further on this first part
before we move on
all right seeing none we can always
circle back if
another thought comes to mind
so the second part during such emergency
any volunteer trained by the department
of health and human services disaster
animal response team who is assisting
evacuated persons and companion animals
shall be considered an emergency worker
under rsa p21 rsa21p416
c
so the important part of this is
at least from my understanding i got
briefed on this a bit this morning
because i didn't quite understand it
originally from the bill when they were
talking about liability it seemed to me
like we were looking to absolve these
workers from having any liability like
if something happened to an animal you
know that they couldn't be sued for that
because animals are property by statute
my understanding is that wasn't the
intent it's it's more about protecting
the person that's doing this like if
they're bitten or i don't know could be
stepped on or whatever thing might
occur that caused them a health issue
so what they're looking for with this
the intent is to protect that person and
make them basically provide workers
compensation benefits it's the easiest
way that i could put it so that if
you know
the person that's trained is bitten by a
dog or scratched by a cat and gets an
infection that they have the ability to
get the appropriate medical care covered
by the state not their personal health
insurance which they might run into
concerns with
so this
addresses that
attempts to anyway at least the way we
worded it hopefully it addresses that
and provides them the protection that
they would need in you know and
guarantees them the health care that
they would need in the event that they
were harmed
during
fulfilling this
being a member of the emergency response
team for the animal shelter
does everybody understand where i'm
any uh any thoughts or questions yeah i
just like something that i i think that
it's um important
i'm glad the language is here that it's
uh that it's volunteer trained by the
department of health so so that there is
actually
so we know who we're dealing with
yes
any
tweaks that you need to
further tweaks you need to see there are
the last portion the number maximum
number of animals per family entering
the hotel or community shelter shall
comply with local ordinances for the
purpose of this section companion animal
means a dog cat or other animal kept in
an enclosure that might typically be
found in a home or typically or lawfully
be found in a home we'll have to play
with that as to how you want to on it
but
i'm certainly open to that change
any any further
thoughts or comments on that i think
yeah representative
i guess my only ques my only point might
be that a word smithing thing and just
made those last two sentences make more
sense
uh before the the
volunteering so like the volunteers
would be the last part and
because we're talking about the animals
and the first part and we're talking
about the animals in the third part
and then the second part is is the
volunteers uh i mean it's it's it
doesn't really make a whole lot of
difference but that's what occurred to
me when i was reading it i can see your
would everybody agree be in agreement
with that
yes
okay i also have a comment
representative erin thank you
um
do we need to specify anywhere here that
the owner is responsible for
[Music]
feeding these animals or caring for
these animals
who ultimately is going to be caring for
these animals in this
there's obviously going to have to be
food provided or
bales of hay or something i don't know
but
sorry i'm just getting text in it on
so yes there is prescribed authority for
the gov governor to declare and issue
orders sorry that was in response to the
earlier part oh i do i actually do i had
found the section that that has to do
what constitutes an evacuation and that
section 4 colon 45
roman numeral 3 uh item c
so
i can give you that
we can we can add that into the text as
as part of you know referring to that
i'm going to go out on a limb here i
think the answer to your question is
i'll have to confirm it as i believe
these trailers would be stock to
appropriately care for the animals that
are there but i'll have to confirm that
okay because that is a good question i i
don't think there would be a requirement
placed okay hold on we're getting it
trailers have food and et cetera and are
set up for i know they're set up for
medical care too so they would be
stocked to take care of the animals that
were there okay and
do
i mean do we care for purposes of the
statute who is paying for that or who is
i think that would be part of the
emergency response team set up just like
it would be in the shelter okay gotcha
representative bixby okay so if we add
the bit about uh other reasonable
accommodation
would that
also have that uh
food
that's a good question and i could see
how that could get dicey
let's think let me think about that a
little bit we can certainly talk about
that representative stapleton
um
do we need a time period
disaster takes place these animals are
scooped up and put in hotel parking lots
trailers
suitable accommodations
are there existing statutes or you know
in the case of a flood in the house is
wiped out there's no place to go back
for the residents or the animals
at what point
does the coverage by state and emergency
fund cease and personal responsibility
take take place
i think my standard answer to with that
would be the same as the person in the
hotel room
that the animals would follow that same
course
and i'm certain that there's some type
of specifications on that but i don't
know them off the top of my head but i
think the intent of this bill would be
to give the animals that same
time of care during that evacuation
order as the person in the hotel is
having
so i'm getting updates that's why i'm
stopping here because
stacy ober from the akc is listening in
and providing you some information she
wasn't able to come in today so
donations would come in during emergency
via animal welfare organizations too
i guess that's standard protocol that
happens
so that's kind of what
i came in with um i'm certainly not
trying to discount the uh the work that
rep gallagher did as well but i think
this sort of takes his and builds upon
i originally was having a difficult time
getting my head around this
and the concerns that were raised in
testimony which is why i reached out and
asked for a little a little help on
putting some of this together because
i just couldn't seem to figure out how
we were going to balance that but i
think
having
the accommodation to have the trailers
there rather than trying to have them in
the hotel solves one of the real major
anything else that you all want to talk
about or add on representative stapleton
yeah i
this is an important bill
an important thing to consider
you know when i was out campaigning it
was like every fourth house had a pet
dog animal
and i was actually surprised to the
extent
of pet ownership and care in our state
and in our country
and it got to be
that realization took me to start
bringing around milk bone dog biscuits
on my campaign walk
to make friends with the dog and that
was good for a vote maybe you know
but um
their number out there and
and stores are marketing increasing
amounts to uh pet foods and pet
accessories and so forth so it's a it's
a big issue
when we have a disaster
it certainly is and from my
understanding again i haven't personally
experienced this but information that
was conveyed to me that
in many cases you know most of the
people during an evacuation order will
have someplace else they can go you know
a friend
a family you know another town another
state whatever they're out of the area
that's affected and
and a lot of those animals can go along
with them but this will affect a small
amount of the community that doesn't
have that option and obviously the
larger the the extent of the evacuation
the more people it would it would
potentially bring in
i mean we're thankfully up here we're
we're not usually um impacted by like
large hurricane areas like new orleans
had and things like that they certainly
had a
extremely large area that was evacuated
new hampshire isn't really conducive to
having that type of an emergency but we
could certainly have something else but
i think this is a good step toward
recognizing that this potential exists
and
i think we're making good strides toward
getting something in statute to take
care of that and those dog biscuits do
make a good emergency snack too if you
[Laughter]
mr chair i have to just say um
my son lives down in florida and they
had a hurricane
that they had to evacuate from
and um
he and his partner have a pet turtle
rather large one
and
they had to they had to leave the area
and as they were going to another place
that was out of the hurricane zone
of course they took their turtle with
them and
it wasn't easy to find a hotel that
would allow them to bring their turtle
inside with them
so something like this is really kind of
definitely
anything further from the committee
before we uh
uh i'm thinking
along the same lines as what was
discussed at the end of the last
subcommittee that we can
i think i think we're fairly close with
this language honestly we can probably
wordsmith this and
we'll just have to have a brief work
section to go over our
final draft and make a recommendation
out to the full committee
representative bixby yeah i i'd agree
and um
having gone over this i'm i'm much
more sanguine about the chances of
getting something put together in
reasonable time
so thank you for the work that you did
in advance well i won't take credit for
much of it i i sort of got it onto paper
and i think again i will i will thank
stacey ober she's sort of the brains
behind drafting a lot of this but
in explaining it to me so i understood
it because
that was a bit of a challenge this
morning i
didn't have a lot of sleep because of
snow plowing duties so i appreciate her
patience
[Laughter]
all right so i guess what we'll do then
is
we'll
get a i'll try and get a draft together
making all these changes and um i'll
individually send it to you all
obviously so that we're not having a
work session offline and you can take a
look at it and then when on our next
next work session we'll
take a look at the changes and see if
it's anything we need to do
representative bixby yeah i propose that
we do the work session after our full
house session next week and not not in
not next week but
following that so that we're not getting
a conflict there yeah i don't i don't
think we'll schedule any for next week
since we do have two days already in
house session so
my feeling is since we're not under the
gun with any of these that we'll we'll
skip next week and
i'll check have to check the
calendar but
uh the availability of the room but
typically tuesdays are available so
i will confirm and we'll put a
notification in the calendar but i i'm
agreeing with you that i don't think it
anything further
any further comments from anybody in the
audience that anything you want to add
well certainly if you uh all come up
with something that you think can help
us in this please send it along and
we're happy to entertain it
all right with that then we're going to
close out this work session on health
you